well to pull a not particularly
spectacular quote from my favorite
underappreciated Denzel Washington movie
everything is motive so we've reached
that point in the month where it is time
once again for me to talk about lgbtq+
representation in the media which does
mean first of all we are gonna swap the
look out and this is my chance to let
anyone know who might be tuning in for
the first time that I don't just talk
about this stuff idly I do have a stake
in it
I am gender-fluid my own personal sense
of my gender and my identity around that
it doesn't it doesn't stay put it tends
to shift around a bit now depending on
how you choose to think about it that
usually puts me either in with the Q or
the T in lgbtq+ so with that established
and with almost enough time to get both
of these earrings in while I did it I
was so close
thought I wouldn't have to stall for
time there we are let's get started
before we get too far along I do want to
mention this is in fact a sponsored
video and before you click off from that
it's not anything that you would have to
pay for you can enjoy it for free this
video is being sponsored by radio versus
the Martians a podcast dedicated to any
and every possible geeky subject from
the cinematic Oubre
of arnold schwarzenegger to whether or
not people need to pull over for the
Ghostbusters - the nature of vigilante
fiction - the best and worst Batman Star
Trek Star Wars it's all over the place
it the host Mike Gillis and Casey Dorne
tend to think of it as the McLaughlin
group for nerds
give it a listen radio versus the
Martians you can find them all
or the place whatever you used to listen
to podcasts podcasts I can speak they
will be on there so they are sponsoring
this video my thanks to them it's a
great podcast give it a listen all right
so this time we are going to talk about
one of those things those arguments that
I come across that just never fails to
frustrates me and I really just need to
pick up this thing this is something I
do from time to time and not only about
just this kind of content because as an
active curator of my comment section
there will sometimes be an argument or a
line of thinking that I see used
repeatedly enough that I feel the need
to just try and address it in video so
that I don't have to keep replying to
comments and just say the same thing
over and over and over again I get to
make a video sort of cleanse myself of
the idea and move on I mean that's why I
have videos on things like the history
of political messaging in Doctor Who or
the concept of think of the children
when it comes to lgbtq+ visibility and
entertainment so this time around I want
to address the concern that I often see
brought up about the motivations behind
things like diverse casts or minority
representation in movies TV comics etc
so to start with an instance from Doctor
Who which will probably never stop being
my go-to reference point a good example
of what I'm talking about
comes up rather frequently when
discussing the lead cast of the current
iteration of the show namely I'm talking
about the fact that the doctor is now a
woman and two out of the three
companions are people of color it's
almost inevitable when conversations
about those facts end up happening
someone will eventually say some version
of it's not that I care about diversity
casting but they're only doing it to
meet a quota or you know I wouldn't my
a female doctor if it wasn't being done
to push an agenda so it's basically
people saying that the problem with
these and many other instances of
increased diversity is that it's being
done for the wrong reasons
speaking personally this is fairly
infuriating to see brought up as much as
it is because intentionally or not it
derails and prevents any conversation
about the actual quality or merit of any
given instance of representation you see
when the confrontation when the
conversation gets stalled on what the
motivations of the creators were and
whether or not those motivations are the
right ones that means we never actually
get to talk about the representation
itself it's it's like it's like when
Congress when when a bill gets stalled
in committee they never actually vote on
the thing because they are too busy
arguing over what and why the thing even
is it's a pretty simple but irritatingly
effective tactic for avoiding actually
talking about diversity itself and this
like most arguments can be done in good
faith where the person who brings it up
has genuine concerns for this aspect or
it can be done in bad faith where
intentionally do railing the
conversation was the intent from the
very beginning and as is generally the
case with online discourse it's it's
almost impossible to be sure which of
those you're dealing with in any given
instance but the end result is no less
frustrating regardless of the motives of
the speaker which is my way of
foreshadowing
where I'm going with all this because
the thing is I for one I'm far more
interested in the actual outcome of
something than I am in the reasons that
those involved had for doing it in the
first place I think most of us tend to
agree that horrible things
can be done for the right reasons or at
the very least for reasons
sincerely believed to be right by the
people doing them there's a reason
everybody knows the phrase the road to
hell is paved with good intentions but
that doesn't seem to be as universally
accepted the flip of that which is that
having impure motives doesn't negate a
positive outcome at its most simplistic
just think about how rich people
engaging in charity causes they get text
benefits for that that means that some
wealthy people their primary if not
their exclusive motivation for
supporting charities at all is for
selfish personally beneficial reasons
the wrong reasons I think most we would
agree but that money is still going to
be used by a Cherry charity to do good
things regardless of why it was donated
in the first place hey you don't even
have to be rich for this kind of thing
to apply I mean look look at local level
charity drives that have prizes raffles
there are people who are participating
because they want the prize and they
really couldn't care less about the
charity at any other time it doesn't
matter though because it still puts
money towards the cause the money given
by the selfish is just as helpful as the
money given by the altruistic cuz I mean
look let's not kid ourselves about this
most people just don't give money to
their local school but they'll buy a
cookie at a bake sale that benefits that
same school because they want a cookie
there was actually a really great
example of this that came up in the news
while I was working on the script for
this video which by the time it comes
out will be Oh have been a few weeks
prior to when you're seeing this so now
the Trump administration launched a
global campaign to combat the
criminalization of homosexuality across
the globe and
that is a good thing now be
not-so-secret reason for doing this is
to put additional pressure specifically
on the country of Iran because of that
nation's human rights record in this
area so I'll be very surprised if that
pressure gets applied in the same degree
or at all in countries like Saudi Arabia
or Russia or once we have better
relationships with so doing this whole
thing in order to target a country we
don't like is not exactly a motivation
I'm in love with but there's still a
great amount of good that could
potentially come out of this regardless
of who started it or why I could keep
listing examples but I hope folks get my
point I just sort of the general premise
that good results can happen regardless
of initial motives so now applying this
principle to representation in media if
we agree that increased diversity is
valuable or at the very least not an
inherent negative in and of itself feel
free to check out the last month's video
as to why representation matters in the
first place
if you actually do need convincing on
that point and then come on back what
this should mean is that why it's
happening should be a minimal part of
the conversation at best to be clear I'm
not saying or even implying that every
instance of representation gets some
kind of automatic pass and a thumbs-up
but let's at least deal with the merits
of the actual representation we're given
rather than never addressing that
because we're debating the reason why we
have it in the first place
of course that's the logical argument
and I say almost every video that I do
on this topic that you can't just logic
people out of some of these positions or
out of a feeling opinions are emotional
and there's an emotional element to this
argument because it circles back to
another video I did a few months ago
linked up
they're talking about the emphasis on
agendas in the current discourse I don't
support these agendas therefore I can't
support anything created that comes
about as a result of those agendas
supposed agendas evoke very emotional
responses which make it very easy to
disregard whether or not the end result
has a positive effect but more than that
it can quickly fall into the realm of
conspiracy theory because it's actually
pretty infrequent for a writer-director
company whoever to actually say in plain
words what their agenda even is so these
supposed to organized agendas the ones
that some people argue negate the value
of representation and diversity more
often than not are really just cobbled
together speculation which then gets
touted as fact I used to mark comments
that made wild claims about the
intention or thoughts of a creator by
replying with citation needed
I still do that sometimes but I don't do
it nearly as much as I used to because I
got really tired of getting back a list
of only tangentially related items often
buried under somebody's think piece
rather than being given a primary source
and then just being shouted at to
connect the dots you know the funny
thing about connecting dots is people
will draw some insanely bizarre lines in
order to connect some of these things
cuz a lot of this isn't logical and even
most of the instant instances that I see
that get pointed to as evidences of
companies laying out their agendas
aren't actually that at least not from
where I sit so let's take Marvel's
initiative which pushed a large number
of new female characters as well as
having female or non-white characters
take up the mantle of previously white
male heroes this is a juicy one now
Marvel did this with Wolverine Iron Man
Hulk and Thor while pumping them the
importance of characters like Captain
Marvel and Falcon
and they were pretty upfront about the
fact that they were doing this which of
course means it got the agenda label
slapped on it pretty quickly but the
thing is even something like this isn't
actually about pushing an agenda not a
politically minded one at any rate
because it's not about ideology it's
about making money
Marvel did it because at the time they
believed it to be a sound business
strategy whether or not it worked out
that way isn't the point the point is
they never would have done this if they
thought it would cause them to lose
money making some kind of political
statement would not be considered worth
the loss or the damage to the IP this is
also the reason that they eventually
reversed a fair number of these changes
because they did what comics always do
they threw a bunch of stuff at the wall
they kept with sticks and they reset the
wreck and the rest back to what it used
to be it's not politics its business
when talking corporations the only
agenda is money any political stance
they appear to take will always have the
underlying motivation of making the
company more money
the reason the entertainment landscape
has long been over saturated with cysts
white heterosexual male characters
happened not by design or sinister
machination or agenda but by a
combination of those traits being the
most common among the people who were
making the entertainment in the first
place write what you know and all that
as well as the presumption that those
people that demographic were the ones
with the most disposable income so it
makes the most sense to appeal to them
most of the time sure go for the niche
market of women people of color every
now and then but the big money for a
very long time throughout our history
what has traditionally been in the hands
of cysts white hetero guys
so the over-representation of that group
didn't happen because of agenda it
happened because of capitalism and the
correction of representation also isn't
being done because of an agenda it's
being done because of capitalism and i
am not trying to make this a capitalism
is bad video I'm just being honest
about what these motivations are for
these moves that these companies make
now there are those who would actually
say that the desire to make money is an
instantaneous taint on increased
diversity but that just kind of circles
back to my original point if you believe
as I do that representation matters and
is important then you pretty much have
to get over the fact that most of the
time it happens or at least gets the
green light to go ahead because somebody
thinks it's gonna make them money that's
especially true when we talk mainstream
representation this actually came up on
the council geeks discord a little while
back yes I get the question sometimes it
does exist but it's a patreon perk so if
you want in just head over to the
patreon yes I can be shameless and
indeed am a capitalist myself after a
fashion so on the discord the topic of
discussion that came up was Disney
hosting an actual official pride event
at some of its resorts but charging
pretty high prices to attend or
participate this bothered some folks and
I do get why I mean a company going
we're on your side give us cash doesn't
exactly fill you with the best feeling
in the world
they're superficially supporting you
while still treating you as nothing more
than a potential consumer except that's
how companies view everybody through the
lens of their value as a consumer so for
me the silver lining and things like the
Disney Park pride event is that an
increasing
of companies believe it is better
business for them to openly support
diversity sometimes at the risk of
alienating consumers who are against it
that means that they believe that team
lgbtq+ Ally is the financially sound
team to be on regardless of how cynical
that reasoning may be it doesn't remove
the value of the representation that
results from that and honestly I take
these kinds of moves as positive
indicators in and of themselves the
people whose job it is to read the
culture and figure out the broadest and
most lucrative appeal for their products
think that diversity representation and
inclusion are going to win and let's not
kid ourselves truly pure motives are
such a rare thing in this world so to
demand them of representation and
entertainment very quickly morphs into
an argument to not even bother having
representation at all because you can
argue in pure intent almost every single
time so you won't see me make that
argument and I can't help but be
frustrated when I see other people
making it it would be amazing if these
companies and artists and writers were
standing by me out of nothing more than
the kindness of their hearts but even if
that's not the reason them being there
still has value the representation still
has value even it's for the
quote-unquote wrong reasons and so we'll
wrap it up there as I said this is yet
another instance of me seeing repeatedly
an argument that I just know I don't
want to hear anymore and that's not me
saying like if I see you making it I'll
delete your comic no I won't you make
your comments respectfully I'll leave
them up but also don't be surprised if I
just reply with a link to this video
because
it's a heck of a lot easier they try to
type all this out in a comment reply so
the reasons for increased diversity and
visibility how much do they matter
my feeling is not very much do you agree
do you feel differently whatever your
thoughts are even if you disagree with
me drop something down in the comments
and let's talk about it respectfully is
all that I ask a whole bunch of stuff to
do down there as well there's buttons
there's links there's the link to radio
verses the margins the patreon my P o
box check them all out or don't that's
okay too because at the end of the day
you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]